cyril hanouna ne nous impose rien et on
peut parler de tout et c'est ça qui est
formidable
[Musique]
alors pour être tout à fait franc je ne
sais pas parce que on sait jamais de
quoi la vie est faite donc j'ai pas vous
dire oui je vais pas vous dire non
peut-être dans quelle partie je ne sais
pas non plus parce que le paysage
politique a explosé donc je ne sais pas
ce qu'il en restera si un jour je
reviens en politique nous sommes sur de
très gros désaccords pendant l'émission
mais sortie du plateau on est dans de
bonnes relations de sympathie et je suis
persuadé que si un jour j'avais la
moindre difficulté il serait là et moi
aussi pour lui alors il y avait plus le
choix parce que la france insoumise a
fait obstruction
donc il fallait en finir mais c'est bien
dommage parce qu'en fait cette réforme
est nécessaire a été malmené et on a ce
résultat maintenant avec une grande
incompréhension des français j'ai trouvé
d'un balances ton poste le plus gros
espace de liberté d'expression c'est à
dire que c'est pour moi l'émission où je
peux tout dire ce que je pense
naturellement sans contrainte donc cyril
hanouna ne nous impose rien et on peut
parler de tout et c'est ça qui est
formidable
[Musique]
j'ai du mal à répondre à cette question
parce que il ya des points de
convergence des personnalités politiques
sont exposés les personnalités
médiatiques aussi
peut-être qu'en télévision il y a un
tout petit peu plus de légèreté
[Musique]
là j'ai rencontré la présidente de
l'association sur le plateau de balances
ton post elle venait témoigner de ce
qu'elle a vécu avec sa soeur a été
assassinée par son conjoint et j'ai été
très touché par son courage son
engagement j'ai eu envie de m'engager à
ses côtés et je me suis proposé donc
pour être la marraine de l'association
et j'essaie vraiment de vrai pour les
aider c'est la seule association en fait
qui s'occupe des familles des victimes
de féminicide et je pense que c'est très
important que nous puissions avancer là
dessus oui il peut et peut-être pas on
ne sait même pas s'il sera candidat
savez la vie politique évolue très vite
donc d'ici 2022 il va se passer encore
beaucoup de choses j'aimerais débattre
contre marine le pen parce que j'aurai
beaucoup de choses à lui dire à lui
opposer donc ce serait pour moi quelque
chose de très intéressant
alors les tenues de nous avons un
plateau nous sont prêtés donc je ne sais
pas où a échoué
cette veste rose bonbon qui nous a valu
un gros buzz
néanmoins elle a été très utile pour
démontrer ce que yassine belattar pense
vraiment des femmes et tout le mépris
qu'il a pour les femmes
donc je remettrai évidemment des vestes
rose bonbon comme j'en ai toujours mis
ça ne va pas changer ma façon de faire
mais en tout cas elle a été révélatrice
de l'état d'esprit de cette personne
[Musique]